The WHO held an emergency meeting...
...to decide whether to declare a public health emergency over the coronavirus.
The death toll is more than 170 with 7,780 confirmed cases worldwide.
In France, a French appeals court acquitted a French cardinal...
...of covering up the sexual abuse of minors in his flock.
Flash floods and landslides triggered by torrential rains have killed at least 9 people...
...and left thousands homeless on Indonesia's Sumatra Island.
In India, a man facing murder charges is holding 20 children hostage in Farrukhabad.
The man had invited them over to his house...
...on the pretext that they would be celebrating his birthday.
Finally from Liberia, the country is down to its last few days' worth of gasoline...
...due to an overestimation of what was left in storage.
A shipment is expected to bring supplies from overseas soon.